Nick good morning thanks for joining us
ya mind on how I may be better style
first what is this I hear the between me
and Alec Baldwin's hair um we were
deciding who had better hair you or Alec
Baldwin and I said Paulie my producer
can you google bad hair day for Nick
Faldo and nothing came up so I must be a
fitness coffee should not Scottish day
and I with a bit of it must be a bad
hairdo you're in there I don't know you
say might much can i just say could I
get a lot of stick especially from got
the wrong lighting I'm still own natural
i did that is my natural color and if
any would like to have a bit against it
i'm more than happy to take that wow wow
yeah it's pretty good i the i voted for
my mom I wouldn't have thought that I
would have thought that there was some
paint there but you said that there's no
they're not I like you know what you
know what Twitter's like they ok I give
you 10 to 1 money goes to my father's
chair I'll take any amount any big
anyway cuz i cleared up to get started
your hair is the jack nicklaus of hairs
not bad yeah not but yeah as long as he
can keep on top that's all I'm worried
about alright so when when tiger comes
in and he's got the trademark red on
like he's ready to how its closing
sunday what what what was your thought
when Tiger walked into the booth was
very wrong either he said I've been up
and I've been in TV to have for 12 years
now and I've actually done in the second
time he came in last year's event that
only the first time he's ever been up
there with a Gemini and yeah bought his
kids and as you said and he was knows
making faces and waving to them all the
time I kind of think he feels a little
uncomfortable up there for a while and
yeah i mean what he's done to his
foundation is fantastic boom work and
but obviously we golfers 12 know where
he is on this rebuild and know what
state is play and body swing and mine
that's what i was trying to get to and
Tino Sehgal it's all on plan and he
doesn't tell you what the plan is of
course he did he's doing it doing a
trump on us as well so um yeah but I
want to know how much as you call
America fatigue factor I mean how long
how many Bulls can he hit in a day
because just playing and playing and
practicing is nothing like playing
competitive Dolph so I'm not so sure I
mean you watch the way he walks he's
very ginger as we would call it way he
walks and I think he's still unfortunate
i feel for the guy I think he's back
he's giving him pain I think all the
time so that's that's pretty rough but
why is he so vague Nick I hey that's
been the question for 20 years I mean I
think he'd always like to give a
different answer to the question never
really given the insight into him or his
life or his thinking and what have you I
me I tried to ask him at times some
Dolph questions and I get answers back
where I've never heard their answer
before so you know say well okay thats
that's what he said so yeah it's very
difficult to read now we will
automatically everybody reads between
the lines or speculate and he teases out
for that every time but not really just
saying you know what is on track if he
was just to say hey it's going to still
be three more months I reckon I could do
it in that or something that would give
everybody I mean the girl fans would
love that to note that the tiger could
could potentially come back out through
your six months but I think physically
it's a forget strong enough to play 54
I'm something semi to old Mia would be
would be it doesn't look like if he
really is having problems walking yeah
it's just a physical test is is way more
than people give golfers credit for
until you sir Nick Faldo CBS sports golf
analyst joining a stand Patrick show but
also you have to get to a point where
you accept your more towel
and you went through this where can i
play can I be comfortable with this the
expectation level from yourself fans the
media that's a hard thing if you said to
Tiger you can go out and play you're
going to compete but you're never going
to win another major but you're going to
be able to go out and be a you know top
50 or 75 could could he accept that or
would you rather not plugged I agree
talk to you that I would say no and I
knew speaking for myself anyone who
starts saying god I can't play how Nick
Faldo used to play and you start
thinking more what what is it he saw
what better to take that the terrible
thing about our game is he a dangle a
carrot in front of you every day to know
tomorrow you might go into 65 meeting I
believe I could do that but could you do
it again the next day Union and you
can't and that's the problem it so it's
it makes you feel as if you can do it
and even now I think how could I play
but you know darn well it's not that and
then you start saying well what is it
Bowl you say well I can't just give
myself an examinee think you know go and
make the cut the open championships
musing oh yeah be for me right now to
make the cowboy fan yeah but say they
say where I'm and because i'm nearly 60
said no when I was 50 you start thinking
but if a great performance is top 20 do
I want that do I want to go through all
that I had to walk away and then who who
cares about you shooting 20-year top 20
or something too yeah i agree with you i
mean tiger was so totally dominant given
that he was unbelievable and for him to
sit and think so what is my bowl well
you know and that's and the another
great thing about our game is is very
very easy to set goals you know you
better obviously get a goal for him and
begin the way I want to win this
tournament so what's the journey what I
means I have to queue a 65 or whatever
and that means is to take the whole I
need to birdie and that means it's three
on I want to edit a template whoosh need
a bit just easy to set goals and
suddenly
the poor guy sitting around unable to
set a goal I mean this is what going on
now for a couple of years and it done no
what is this new goal he's his new goal
just to get good enough to get back and
play and then see where he is that's a
tough one I mean I took me I think it
can be a tough decision for him to make
that two maybe let go and say hey I
hadn't a fantastic trip I'm fortune my
back is a as could tell the you know
maybe in a future golfer I know that we
keep score with majors but I'm curious
who had the biggest impact on golf if I
said Arnold Palmer Jack Nicklaus or
tiger woods well I think we're waiting
you have to say Tyga because we've
documented literally every single Scotia
when Tiger came on tour it changed
television you know we shall get
corrected but we basically covered him
wall-to-wall from the mini Walt in the
car park to finishing it on the second
72nd green winning with his famous fist
pump what have you so people reckon I
tell me what but the Arnold did first
gaining the popularity but as we know
the television only came on and showed
the lychee the last three holes I
believe you know for a long time before
they even got to cover in the back nine
at the Masters and so Tyga has been in
this total knee total Walter walk media
area so we know everything about his
game and his shots and we know we've
seen famous shots at target it on the
whatever the sixth and seventh hole on
some golf course well you never saw that
before because it wasn't televised I'm
sure jack and i love the unbelievable
shots but the only the trees can
remember no sir and a few fans that were
there but I think that's what's made
targethi you know the mega story is more
likely to happen in a year Tigers in
contention at a major he's not playing
wow I mean yeah you put me on the put me
on the spot but I would and I want to
say I didn't order good but I think I'm
leaning towards he may not be competing
I think he's got to get when you see how
tight that back is just walking how is
he going to get just being the Gulf
again and then gets everything from
physical technical get his confidence
back and we had to compete against these
guys and get the reps in to compete
against these guys I mean there's a
dozen as a dozen great golfers out there
every week and the standard of golfers
he probably seen is was pretty down good
right now I put him on tough really
tough go course isn't he and they can
play still shoot lights out before I let
you go can you give me the sports angle
on brexit what's happening or what will
help all right I was trying to liken it
to the hole location on the 18th hole at
the Congressional another little
Peninsula greenhouse saying I could say
early in the week I said that that's
basically Great Britain out on a on the
limb right now let me get it so it's
pretty amazing i mean i don't i don't
follow politics it's politics enough but
i know that's it's amazing how the
country's got in one direction and then
our and they told him a few more facts
and then i'll get oops and there's a
really big oops you know I felt we
should stay in Europe I mean it makes
sense your yo you can't be the cornish
up against a giant supermarket Eddie boy
just doesn't work in in life and the
opportunity to create so that so the the
college students and others of business
banking my goodness so and now people
are woken up and go oh why don't you
tell me what I know I know I don't think
hable realized what they were voting on
yeah i agree i mean i was i was in
england in a couple of weeks ago right
before i get two or three days before it
and they come on TV and they didn't give
you anything talking about is it good
for the farmers and they couldn't give
anything anybody definitive answer could
say yes or no they couldn't come up with
any and you're the further they should
have just run the facts of real cold
facts no people's opinion what
means and so it's ya little o Great
Britain got a bit of a wall opens know
how sweet amazing amazing Nick thank you
you and Jim did a great job and trying
to pin Tiger down which isn't easy and
we appreciate you joining us this
morning I think that that hike tears
Nick found a sir Nick Faldo CBS golf
analyst six-time major winner the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience